une scène plutôt inattendu en plein pont
finement mais dans ce quartier elle est
loin d'être exceptionnel ce soir là des
juifs ultra-orthodoxes organiste une
manifestation même si certains portent
un masque en pleine pandémie de
coronavirus les distances de sécurité
sont loin d'être respectées en
patrouille dans les rues du quartier
des policiers tentent de les rappeler à
l'ordre laisse moi tranquille
j'étais déjà expliqué je veux juste
respirer de l'air frais je rentre chez
moi après certains habitants sont
sermonnés avant même qu'il ne franchisse
le seuil de leur porte
la présence de ces patrouilles ne plaît
pas ce soir là des policiers seront
notamment la cible de pierres
le lendemain autres scènes de violence
des jeunes ont incendié des bennes à
ordures elles ont été placées en plein
milieu de la route
les pratiques dénoncées par une partie
de la communauté
il y en a qui pensent que les policiers
sont contre les population religieuse en
raison de certaines restrictions comme
la police essaye de les disperser et
d'arrêter ceux qui vont à l'encontre des
restrictions ces derniers jours ils
protestent contre la violence que la
police utilise pour mettre fin à ces
violations
nouvelle nuit de manifestation dans le
quartier beaucoup de jeunes de la
communauté sont de sortie sur leurs
pancartes
il annonce une forte mobilisation pour
les prochains jours un policier demande
à un couple de ne pas rester dehors
s'il vous plaît restez chez vous montrer
l'exemple en israël dans les communautés
très religieuse
on préfère écouter son rabbin plutôt que
le gouvernement et beaucoup choisissent
de se couper des moyens de
télécommunication résultat les juifs
ultra orthodoxes qui sont une minorité
dans la population israélienne constitue
plus de la moitié des personnes
contaminées dans le pays